we left off in the last video trying to
solve for gamma we set up this equation
and then we had the insight that well
look we could particular we could pick a
particular event that is connected by
light signal and in that case x would be
equal to ct but also x prime would be
equal to c t prime and if gamma's going
to hold for any transformations between
events between x and x prime and t and t
prime it should definitely hold for this
particular event and so maybe we could
use this to substitute back in and solve
for gamma so that's exactly what we're
going to do right now so for all the x's
i'm going to substitute it with the cts
so i'm going to substitute it with the
ct so x substitute ct x i'm going to
substitute c t
x substitute c t
and that's it and then all the x primes
i'm going to substitute with a c t prime
with a c t prime
so x prime c t prime
x prime
c t prime and then i have an x prime
here so it's going to be c t prime so
let's simplify and now i'm going to
switch to a neutral color so i'm going
to now have i'm now going to have c
times c times t times t prime so that's
going to be
c
squared actually let me just keep using
the t
t primes t
t primes i'll still do a little bit of
color coding t prime
is equal to
gamma squared
times
so it's going to be c squared
c times c is c
let me do that in the yellow color
so
c squared t times t prime
t
times
prime
and then we have plus
c
times v
times t times t prime
plus
c
times
v
i'll just write it this way c times
t
times v
times t prime
and then we have minus
minus let's see we're gonna have a c
here
so minus
c
minus c
times t
t times
v times t prime
times v
times t prime i wrote this v in blue
just so it matches up with this and we
see something interesting is about to
happen and then finally we have minus v
squared
minus v squared times t times t prime
times t
times t prime
it doesn't look that much simpler but
we're about to simplify it a good bit
and so we're going to get these two
middle terms cancel out
so plus c t v t plus prime minus c t v t
prime
so those are going to cancel out
and then every other term
has a t t prime in it so let's divide
both sides of this equation by t t prime
and so we're going to get if we divide
the left hand side by t t prime we're
just going to be left with c squared and
then we're just going to divide
everything by t t prime
and there are a whole thing has
simplified quite nicely our equation is
now i'll continue it over here
our equation now is
c squared
is
equal to
gamma squared
is equal to gamma squared
times
c squared
minus v squared
and close the parentheses
and now we can divide both sides by c
squared minus v squared and we would get
gamma squared and i'm going to swap the
sides too so gamma squared is equal to
c squared
over
c squared i'll write it all in one color
now c squared minus v squared now if we
like we can divide the numerator and
denominator by c squared in which case
this will be equal to 1
over
c squared divided by sq squared is 1 and
then v squared divided by c squared and
we are in the home stretch now we can
just take the square root of both sides
and we get we deserve a little bit of a
drum roll actually let me continue it up
here where i have some real estate
we get gamma
is equal to the square root of this well
the square root of 1 is just 1
over the square root of the denominator
square root of
1 minus
v squared over c squared so hopefully
you found that as satisfying as i did
because all we did
we just thought about well the symmetry
if x prime is going to be some scaling
factor times the traditional galilean
transformation and x is going to be some
scaling factor times the traditional
galilean transformation from the prime
coordinates we use that and it's
important that we use one of the
fundamental assumptions of special
relativity that the speed of light is
absolute in either frame of reference
that x divided by t is c that x prime
divided by t prime is going to be equal
to c for some event that's associated
with a a light beam
we use that to substitute back in and we
were able to solve for a gamma so this
looks pretty neat and so some of you all
might be saying well what about what
about our we've so we've been able to do
the derivation for the
x coordinates but what about the the
lawrence transformation for the t and t
prime coordinates and i'll let you think
about how we do that and i'll give you a
clue it's just going to be a little bit
more algebra and we're going to do that
in the next video